hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on new world again and
they just released another blog post
about player housing and kind of the
structure in the system that's gonna be
going on so as long as they're gonna
recap that blog post as always
so definitely like the V if you do enjoy
subscribe for a new and let's get
started with today's video first up the
article says this player housing is an
exciting at recent addition to new world
this highly requested feature will give
players the opportunity to own and
personalize homes across HRM we want
players to feel like they have the roots
in the world to experience ownership
security and stability in a threatening
and unpredictable land if you have not
read our settlements and governance
article please check that out first
it'll provide you with some additional
context for this blog I've already
recapped this blogger to be in the I on
the top right so if you want to go check
that out after this video or right now
definitely go do that at this moment but
they talk about house ownership it says
in aeternum
every settlement has a variety of houses
available to purchase multiple players
can purchased the same physical home
location but they will only be able to
see their property in dacor unless they
are visiting another player's home if
you want to spend time in your home with
guests our houses support a full party
group of five all you need to do is have
someone visit your home and then they
can have them in a group with you in
order to be eligible to purchase a house
you must first raise your standing
within that settlements territory to
raise your standing in the territory you
might you want to live in it is
important to get involved with the daily
activities of that territory like
killing creatures completing faction
missions working on projects and
crafting items once you have reached a
high enough standing level and your
character has reached level 20 you can
unlock the ability to own a home in that
territory settlement if you want to own
more than one house you could do that
too as long as you meet the requirements
for house ownership but a territory you
do not need to own the maximum number of
houses you'll be able to buy another one
so I'm not entirely sure that they just
stated that this game is going to have a
max rank of 20 I feel like housing and
stuff like that isn't necessarily
considered endgame content there might
be things featuring the houses that you
can do for endgame content but I don't
think the whole structure of housing in
general is going to be so I don't think
the highest-ranked is gonna be 20
although I totally could be wrong in
that front already though we have two
images and the first one is a fellow
player purchasing a house he has 960
gold and the price is going to be caught
thing about 2000 with the property tax
being 200 gold a week it required to
maintain the house it's going to be very
similar to the territories and it for
the governor and the council which like
I said we covered in the last video this
is all going to be about you know paying
the property tax and making sure that
you can actually upkeep the house so
that you can keep the payment going that
you can keep the house and then the
payment goes to the governor so that he
can keep the territory running for
housing features it seems like you can
have trophies maybe by killing bosses or
specific enemies and you get buff I'm
not exactly sure what that means by
placing trophies and getting buff maybe
this is just like a buff that you get or
a debuff to enemies or maybe this is
just some other game mechanic within the
game on top of that there's also fast
traveling from any location and then
there's also decorating with furniture
and pets so pets are confirmed which is
pretty cool and then you can of course
preview the house from the outside and
then have the availability to purchase
it on the next side it shows the
decoration mode of what you're gonna be
doing when you customize houses and it
shows a guy trying to customize house
very very bare-bones I mean there's dirt
and [ __ ] all over the floor there's not
a single piece of furniture or carpet
that I'm seeing throughout this entire
home this is probably very bare-bones or
recently just bought and not customized
so you have lots of options to be able
to customize with things it seems like
it's gonna be chairs vases tables plants
bookshelves doors candles trophies beds
a bunch of different things you can
choose and then everything within those
as well so obviously this is gonna be
very very unique to your own home and
it's gonna make a lot of homes very
unique to other players throughout the
game the question though is how are you
going to be earning this stuff do you
just get this stuff right away or do you
get like that Pelt that you see in the
middle as that pail only going to be
accessible if you kill that specific
enemy and you take its pelt
with that dog on the left as well how do
you get that dog you know all these
different questions hopefully will be
answered later in the blog post but if
they aren't then we'll just have to
speculate also it seems like just by the
fact that there's a mouse being dragged
on the screen as well it seems like this
is going to be able to be placed
wherever you want this isn't going to be
like alright you could just pick the
bookshelf and in the corner of your
house there's always going to be a
bookshelf it's no I could choose to put
the bookshelf right next to the
fireplace I can put my dog next to it
it's gonna make the customization very
very unique per player as I've stated
next up is house variety and houses
range in different
sizes features and cost some houses
overlook the center of town while others
have balconies with nice views over the
settlement walls some houses have
exterior areas for decoration while
others simply feature a front and back
porch there are a variety of locations
and styles to choose from in each
settlement the settlements themselves
also have distinct aesthetics with house
design and for friends specific to that
settlement after purchasing a house you
could personalize your space you have
added we've added hundreds of items for
you to be able to customize your home
everything from tables and chairs the
decorative garden plants and hanging
finds can now if we design a property to
reflect your tastes pieces of furniture
and ornamental items can be crafted by
players and purchased while other items
supposed to be found by exploring and
looting the world under adventures in a
tournament you can even find pets to
bring home with you and on this picture
we have what's called the wins word
house which I'm assuming is the house
right in front of this person and then
we have Jeannie's residence
Tasos at Vino's cupcakes Jensen's
merchants and team's residents as well
it seeming like they're trying to show
that this house is owned by multiple
different players and it also seems like
there's house points which once again
hopefully will be talked about later in
the blog but I'm assuming the more stuff
that you add and the more rare items
that you have within your house the more
points you get thus meaning you have a
cooler looking house so it seems like
Jeannie here with this 1430 points has a
lot better than Jensen's at twelve
hundred and eight and then of course you
could just press ENTER and then you can
enter a player's home and see all of
their Dacor and I'll see I don't think
that's a bad idea especially if you're
thinking about getting that house you
might be able to get a bit of references
from a lot of other players and oh you
know he put that bookshelf in the corner
you know what that actually looks really
really solid when I get to my house when
I get my house at this specific one
maybe I'll put the bookshelf in that
corner or damn you know that Pelt looks
really really nice on the carpet I think
I'm gonna put it there when I get mine
once you purchase house you must pay a
small property tax on it to maintain it
this property tax is paid to the
controlling company of the settlement
while failing to pay your property taxes
won't get you evicted from your house it
will stop mechanics like house recall
and trophy buffs from being functional
to you additionally while you can still
visit your decorate at home while the
property tax is unpaid you cannot
rearrange your decorations nor will your
house be eligible to be displayed to
others and then more on that below when
you own a house you'll be able to use it
as a recall
turn emissive a stand dangerous place in
the ability to recall home over great
distances is a very powerful one in
addition to the recall ability it's
possible to create powerful magical
decorations to give your character buffs
when they are placed on display in your
home these trophies can do things like
give you an advantage in combat against
particular enemy types or improving your
crafting abilities however each house
can only have so many trophies on
display at one time so you'll need to
consider which advantages you want to
have on your specific adventure there
are social benefits as well when you
pass through a settlement you can see
homes owned and decorated by other
players to determine which home other
players see by default there's a
competition behind the scenes by
decorating your house expertly and
earning lots of territory standing your
house gets shown off to everyone that
comes through a settlement who does not
own the same house as you you can even
see where you stand against other
players that owned the same house that
the housing menu so you know what your
competition is which I'm assuming is
what the picture that we looked at just
a second ago which confirms that we are
correct in that and then lastly for the
blog post it says building a community
when a player finds a place to call home
in a settlement they are joining a
community of allies skilled crafters
adventuring partners and even
adversaries players can invest in making
their house and eights are them few
players can invest in making their house
and it turn them feel like a home with
furniture and decorations pets and
trophies that give them bonuses on their
adventures or in their favorite trade
skills we hope that our players homes
become special to them not only as a
familiar place to return after an
exciting adventure but also a place to
share with friends and show off to
others and then of course the
screenshots are from the Alpha so all
these will probably be changed during
the beta maybe looking a little better
or maybe the designs of stuff will look
a little bit different overall I must
say I got to admit the housing thing has
me intrigued about this for sure I
wasn't exactly really really big in
terms of the settlement stuff and the
governing thing I've never been really
big to you know be the giant governor
that taxes everybody although I might
delve into that a little bit when new
world just for the fun of it I'm
definitely intrigued though on this
house and customization I'm a huge
sucker for customization I always like
when this game has given me a lot of
options and ways to do it so the ability
to make my house incredibly unique to
pretty much every single player in this
game that's gonna be something I cannot
wait to see and see how that plays out
obviously they mentioned that there's
gonna be trophies that give you buffs
and then a bunch of other things you
have to collect and then
you know what can you collect how are
you gonna find these pets are we gonna
find the pelts if you kill some giant
giant boss let's just say it's a dragon
for example you get its giant head that
you can put in your house can you get it
scales and put it on the floor like how
is that all gonna work and I'm super
excited to see how that works hopefully
they'll show it in the beta because that
sounds amazing
regardless they'll let me know what you
guys think about the housing stuff in
the comments below but what that like to
be if you do enjoy subscribe for free
new take care guys the beta is slowly
slowly approaching we have a couple more
months I know there's been some people
getting alpha access but of course that
will not be having they won't have
gameplay for that kind of thing just yet
because of NDA's so hopefully with the
closed beta we'll be able to see a lot
more gameplay and maybe I'll even get to
record so I'm going to show you guys as
well to kind of get the gist of what's
happening with this game and other
features they haven't mentioned yet but
yeah like I said like to me if you do
enjoy subscribe for new take care guys
have a ghoster day and peace out
[Music]
[Music]
you